- Welcome back, y'all.
We are here with the cast of
the Super Mario Brothers Movie
which is in theaters everywhere in April.
We got Chris Pratt,
Charlie Day,
Keegan-Michael Key,
and Jack Black.
(audience cheers and applauds)
So, you've all been here
before except for Bowser.
Except for Jack.
- Oh my God. It's my firsties.
- It's your first.
- Jack's first time.
- But we've partied before.
We did a charity thing together and-
- And the first time,
you don't even remember.
I sat next to you at the...
I think I was still on Idol.
- Oh yeah.
- But it was whenever Michael
Jackson accepted the award
that wasn't an award.
- Oh yeah!
- And it was like, "Happy Birthday"
and he said, "Thank you
for being the Artist
of the Millennium."
And everyone was like, "Hmm?"
- It was a crazy moment that we shared.
- [Kelly] That was at
that one too, anyway.
- I remember that.
- [Kelly] I remember sitting
next to you 'cause I love you.
- Aww. Feeling's mutch.
- But anyway, yeah, I just-
- Hey, you got pipes for days.
We should do a duet one of these days.
- I want to!
(audience cheers and applauds)
You should've been my partner
on the Kellyoke today.
You would've killed it. It was like-
- [Jack] Let's do this.
- I shredded.
So, basically 'cause my voice is shot
but I actually love that
y'all are all musical.
Everyone sitting here is musical.
I mean, Tenacious D, obviously.
- Little rock opera.
(audience applauds)
- Was that your first
love when you were a kid?
Did you think you would...
- No, I was a real ham
and it didn't matter if it was
singing or acting, whatever.
I just liked to get up in front of a crowd
and I was doing both from an early age.
I was singing and acting.
Yeah. Putting on a show.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Didn't really matter.
Old school showman.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Well, Keegan, you're the same.
You do musical theater,
you do all the things.
Was your first love
music or was it acting?
- No, the first thing I wanted
to be was a veterinarian.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- Yes. I love animals so much.
I used to sit with my dad
and watch Jacques Cousteau's
or Marlin Perkin's Wild Kingdom.
Anybody who's my age and
knows what I'm talking about.
But, at any rate, I wanted
to be a veterinarian
but then I got into theater
as I got into high school
and then, like most people in high school,
a lot of people start in musical theater.
- Yeah.
- [Key] So I did that,
and then just recently in my career,
that's the thing I've been kind of doing.
I think I'm-
- [Kelly] You're great at it.
- I think I've sung in the last four
of the last six things I've worked on.
- I know, that's what I'm saying.
You're incredible.
I always wonder what was the first love?
I love asking people.
You play seven instruments, I feel like.
You play a lot of instruments.
- Yeah.
When I was in eighth
grade or seventh grade,
I was in school band
and I played trombone.
And I had a sweet sweatshirt
that would say your name
and your instrument.
So, I had this sweatshirt
that said "Charlie Trombone."
- "Charlie Trombone."
- Which became my nickname
which was cool with everyone
except girls.
(everyone laughs)
And so I gave up the trombone.
That's how I-
- Women killed the dream.
- Yeah, you know.
- You're going in my phone
as "Charlie Trombone."
- [Charlie] Okay. That's cool.
That's good by me.
- [Jack] That's pretty awesome.
- Time to hit "edit"
in our contacts, yeah.
- [Kelly] I know you play guitar.
- [Chris] I do. Yeah.
- You played in Parks and Rec.
Was music a first love of yours?
- Well, I always really loved music.
I had a friend growing up,
Josh, who played guitar
and when I decided to
go to community college
after high school I was
looking through the classes
and there was theater
and there was guitar.
And so I was like, "I'm
gonna try those two out,"
and I made it one semester in college.
And by the third or fourth
day of playing the guitar,
I learned like three
chords and I was like,
"I'm done with school."
(Kelly laughs)
"I'm gonna go-"
- You're my daughter.
- [Chris] And sit and play music
in the quad at the school
with my guitar case open
and get money like they do.
(Key laughs)
And I started making money.
And I basically dropped out
of school and just played
guitar.
- To busk. Okay.
- To busk for a little bit.
- I didn't know that.
That's a good one.
- This is my daughter.
I'm like, "Oh, do you wanna take lessons?"
'Cause she'll start playing.
She goes, "I already know how."
And I'm like, "Okay, no you don't."
(everyone laughs)
I'm not the participation ribbon mom.
I'm like, "No, you don't."
I'm like, you gotta really spell it out.
They're very confident
though at a young age
and just think, yeah, you're
not playing Beethoven.
It was like (imitates
pressing piano keys).
(audience cheers and applauds)
We're back with Chris Pratt, Charlie Day,
Keegan-Michael Key, and Jack Black.
Y'all give it up.
(audience applauds)
Together they star the
Super Mario Brothers Movie
in theaters everywhere in April.
All right, so, Keegan, you
started out doing improv,
so what's a memory that will
unfortunately stay with you?
- Well, one thing I
think that's interesting,
especially the rest of these guys
who've improvised, you know?
Improvising with other people
is one of the great joys
of my life.
- The energy of it.
- [Key] The energy of it,
and the give and take of it,
and what we call "Yes, and-ing."
The hardest part is that
you can't always control
what the audience is gonna say.
So sometimes you'll ask for a suggestion
and there's one thing that
no matter what you do,
if you ask for a
profession, you could say,
"So, Ladies and gentlemen,
just gimme a date in history."
"1776!"
"Okay, great, that's wonderful.
Can I have a suggestion of an occupation?"
"Proctologist!"
- Every time.
- "Great. What if we try
a different occupation?"
Every time you ask it'll just be like,
"Can I get a profession?"
"Proctologist!"
Every audience, no matter where you are.
First suggestion.
Proctologist.
- [Kelly] Says a lot about this audience.
- Says a lot about our
society, doesn't it?
"Okay, how about not proctologist."
"Gynecologist!" "Okay. All right.'
- Okay, cool.
Switching it up.
- They're into science which is cool.
[Key Laughs]
- They're the anatomy.
- Well, 'cause everyone's thinking,
"What's the funniest thing I can say?"
and of course it goes
straight to the butt.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Key] Because poop is funny.
Poop is funny.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. Says my six year old.
So, what about you, Chris?
Any early onstage memories
that you'd rather forget?
- Oh man, I remember doing
standup comedy in Seattle
at this little place called Giggles.
It was like an open mic kind of thing.
And I was like the...
I was funny in high school
people thought I was funny
and I used to make people
laugh but getting up on a stage
and doing it's a totally
different scenario.
- [Kelly] Like a planned hilarious moment.
- [Chris] Yeah, because you can be funny
around your friends because
you catch 'em off guard.
You're like, "I wasn't expecting you
to say a joke just now."
- Right, right, right.
- But taking away the surprise
and being like, "Say a joke."
- Right, right right.
- You're like, "I don't know how."
So I had a whole list of various jokes
that I thought I was gonna
go through and then my guitar
and I was gonna do a
whole bit and I was okay.
But then I made the mistake
of leaving my guitar case up there
with my list of jokes and
the next comic came up
and took my list out and just-
- Ripped.
- Destroyed me.
- [Key] Are you kidding me?
- Just made so much fun of me
and my list of jokes.
- Oh no, Chris.
- [Kelly] I mean, kind-
- Where are you now?
Where are you now?
(everyone laughs)
- Still at Giggles.
- Yeah, I think he's still at Giggles.
- Carrot Top, you son of a!
(everyone laughs)
- It was Jerry Seinfeld.
- Looking back though
it's kinda funny. (laughs)
- You gotta take some lumps,
I'll tell you. You gotta take-
- That's just material for days.
Like, "Well, you just handed it to me."
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, and it wasn't...
There was a reason he went to the list.
He wasn't being mean.
My stuff was so bad that
he had to make fun of it.
- It is interesting
though when people think
that you're funny but it
doesn't translate always.
Or you think your friend is very funny
and they do something and you're like,
"Oh, why didn't that translate?"
That is a hard thing to do.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I think, yeah.
Jack, I heard that your first improv game,
I hope this is true,
was at a Passover Seder.
Is that true?
- Yup.
- [Kelly] Okay, so just
how does that happen?
Like, what kind of games
are played at that?
- It was an amazing...
I remember we had the Passover Seder
at a friend's house and
she was an amazing lady.
She was a Holocaust survivor, actually.
And she had this incredible spirit
and energy of creativity
and joy and she said,
"Now we're done with the Seder.
We're gonna play a freeze game.
Come on, everyone come
to the living room."
And we played these Viola Spolin games.
They're improv games and I was so into it.
I just wanted to be up
onstage the whole time
in this little living
room and getting laughs
and that's where I first caught the bug.
Yeah.
- [Kelly] That energy is awesome.
I don't know it in the comedic way,
but just playing on stage, musically,
you have nights when
people are really into it
and you're feeding off of
it and then you're like,
"Wow, they must have thought
somebody else was playing
like Pink."
And you have nights where it's just like,
"Oh, it's not going like I thought."
And you feed off of that
energy, I feel like.
- Yeah, you know it when you try it,
if you feel that electricity.
You can feel it in a
lot of different games.
What's the one where you you
try to guess what the person?
The movie?
- Charades.
You know, any kind of game that
that requires you to get up
and put on a little show.
You can feel that.
I could play charades for hours
and hours when I was a kid
because it was so fun
to put on a little show.
- And, because you couldn't
think of the word "charades,"
the game would probably go really long.
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Took so long.
(Key stammers)
- [Chris] Game! Game!
- [Kelly] It's like...
- [Charlie] Game!
Two words!
(Key stammers)
Two syllables.
- You sit.
Can't talk.
- It's like grunting. (laughs)
- Okay, a chair.
What's the next syllable?
(Key imitates drinking sound)
Oh yeah!
(Kelly laughs)
- It's make fun of Jack day.
Everything I do, you guys
are trying to sabotage me.
- Jack, we're not. Jack.
- They left you hanging with the costume.
- All I'm doing is trying to think
of how I'm gonna get
you guys back someday.
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Who's really winning though?
I think you're really winning.
- He is winning.
- Charlie, I have to ask,
what was your first time
in front of an audience?
- Oh man, yeah.
Four years old and I got to-
- [Kelly] Wow, that's young.
- To walk out on stage of a school play
holding the sign that said "Intermission."
(everyone laughs)
- And I thought to
myself, "I'm gonna crush.
I'm gonna walk out there.
I'm gonna hold this thing upside down."
But I didn't tell anybody.
I walk out, hold it upside down
and get the big huge "aw,
isn't that cute" laugh.
And I thought, "I got what it takes, man."
- [Chris] That's the move.`
- I can do this. I can do this.
- They're not gonna remember the play
but they remember the kid
with the intermission sign.
- It was my best performance.
It's downhill since then.
(Kelly laughs)